what i'd like to do in this video is a
few more examples recognizing the slope
and y-intercept given an equation
so let's start with something that we
might already recognize let's say we
have something of the form y is equal to
5 x plus 3. what is the slope and the
y-intercept in this example here
well we've already talked about that we
can have something in slope-intercept
form where it has the form y is equal to
the slope which people use the letter m
for the slope times x plus the
y-intercept which people use the letter
b for
so if we just look at this m is going to
be the coefficient on x right over there
so m
is equal to 5 that is the slope
and b is just going to be this constant
term plus 3 so b is equal to 3. so this
is your y
intercept so that's pretty
straightforward but let's see a few
slightly more involved examples
let's say if we had form
y
is equal to 5 plus 3x
what is the slope and the y-intercept in
this situation
well it might have taken you a second or
two to realize how this earlier equation
is different than the one i just wrote
here it's not 5x it's just 5 and this
isn't 3 it's 3x so if you want to write
it in the same form as we have up there
you can just swap the 5 and the 3x it
doesn't matter what or which one comes
first you're just adding the two so you
could rewrite it as y is equal to 3x
plus 5 and then it becomes a little bit
clearer that our slope is 3 the
coefficient on the x term and our
y-intercept is 5
y-intercept
let's do another example let's say that
we have the equation
y is equal to 12
minus x pause this video and see if you
can determine the slope and the
y-intercept
all right so something similar is going
on here that we had over here the
standard form slope intercept form we're
used to seeing the x term before the
constant term so we might want to do
that over here so we could rewrite this
as y is equal to
negative x plus 12
negative x plus
12.
and so from this you might immediately
recognize okay my constant term when
it's in this form that's my b that is my
y intercept so that's my y
intercept right over there but what's my
slope
well the slope is the coefficient on the
x term but all you see is a negative
here what's the coefficient well you
could view negative x as the same thing
as negative one x
so your slope here is going to be
negative
one
let's do another example let's say that
we had the equation y is equal to 5 x
what's the slope and y intercept there
at first you might say hey this looks
nothing like what we have up here this
is only i only have one term on the
right hand side of the equality sign
here i have two
but you could just view this as 5x plus
zero and then it might jump out at you
that our y intercept is zero and our
slope is the coefficient on the x term
it is equal to five
let's do one more example
let's say we had y is equal to negative
seven what's the slope and y-intercept
there
well once again you might say hey this
doesn't look like what we had up here
how do we figure out the slope or the
y-intercept
well we could do a similar idea we could
say hey this is the same thing as y is
equal to
zero times x
minus seven
and so now it looks just like what we
have over here and you might recognize
that our y intercept is negative seven
y intercept is equal to negative seven
and our slope is the coefficient on the
x term it is equal to
zero and that makes sense for a given
change in x you would expect zero change
in y because y is always negative seven
in this situation